a smoke Sundberg
it all started on a rainy day in the
bang team Bleacher Report's led by
Golden State Warriors superstar DeMarcus
boogie cousins hey what's up guys it's
your boy bull I'm here to assemble my
team vs team IGN led by internet
sensation and pro gamer Noah J hey guys
my name is Noah J and I've been told
that you are the best players here at
IGN we're gonna be assembling a squad
today and we're gonna be playing some
division to wear as person I'm looking
for as a sharpshooter let's see who can
shoot the best we need the best marksman
anyone who could take out snipers at
range Tom Clancy's the division to the
Sharpshooter specialization uses a
powerful sniper rifle to pick off
enemies from a distance team bleacher
report hit the court to pick their
sharpshooter by challenging players to
score as many points as possible on a
30-second clock
[Applause]
team IGN pick two sharpshooters
head-to-head in a mission to determine
who could bait the most sniper kills
with the most headshots by 15 we have
Sydney number two we need the best
demolitionists anyone who can take down
those big targets big damage big AoE
second guy I'm looking for is the
demolitions he's gonna put you guys in
knockerball let's see who can make the
most destruction the demolitionists uses
explosives and a signature grenade
launcher to smoke out entrenched enemies
and create chaos on the battlefield team
bleacher report pit contestants
head-to-head in knocker balls to see who
could stay on their feet and destroy
their opponents walls
I hurt my foot
hey boogie don't worry man you got
yourself a demolition it's right here
team IGN had their demolitionist
competitors race to net the most routine
launcher kills in a mission in the
division to
with the most a OE damage and most kills
with the grenade launcher Bobby a lot of
men [ __ ] you got a good job good job
good job
number three the survivalist which is
gonna be the support the healer for the
team the last spot we're looking for the
survivors we're putting you guys through
a crazy off because let's see who can
survive the survivalists uses traps out
with their opponents while dealing
killing blows with a crossbow equipped
with explosive bolts team Bleacher
Report's had contestants negotiate a
treacherous obstacle course to find
their most capable survivalist
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh survivalist I always managed to come
through at the very end meanwhile team
IGN had players compete for crossbow
kills on enemy target
yes
[Applause]
the most damaged with the crossbow is
Josh suck and now the final challenge
team IGN vs. team bleacher report in a
race to finish an endgame mission in the
division - the first team to hit the
mission complete screen wins 1 2 3 give
one to a smoke somebody
lighten up lighten up
he's almost down what's up what's up
nice good job
[Music]
I got him your mother oh no he got rest
oh he's going down he's going down
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah man you're pretty good at this
game division - I'll give you your data
victory thank you but I have my dad and
you meet me on the court I gotta go bye
Xbox one get the Division two